My Philosophy always with buying a home
is buy it when you're ready it's a great
investment we want everyone to own a
home we want you to have a primary
residence when you're ready it's a great
part of your financial picture and so
you know you have to really be able to
kind of take the noise and everything
going on that you hear at the news and
everything and and kind of mute all of
that and say okay where are we
financially and as long as your payment
is within that 25 of your take-home pay
you're on a 15-year fixed rate and and
if all of that math still works for you
and you have a good down payment then
you can move forward with it but you
have to know mathematically yeah we're
going to be paying more in interest